[Music]
Oh what's going on YouTube is it not
that time - game will be all gather our
thoughts think about the past year and
think of a new year's resolution and
much like every year um we're gonna do
[ __ ] I thought to myself YouTube why do
we always make new year's resolutions
but we never ever do them what's the
whole damn point I found out the reason
why we don't do them is because we don't
know how to make them correctly hey some
of y'all ghetto ass people don't even
know what a New Year's resolution is so
I'm here to help y'all out with that one
LG has - lets get ghetto people stop
making your New Year's resolutions [ __ ]
that you're already supposed to do you
should have already been doing that [ __ ]
in the first place well this year I'm
gonna be my kids holding the New Year's
resolution that's a mandated
court-ordered talk about dishing you
ain't gon break parole you get a last
mother first thing I have a family
member who didn't know what a new year's
goal was and this fool oh well actually
he came up to me and he told me he was
gonna change his life he was gonna
change to that and in that process this
is what he told me no joke if you want
to hear my new year's goals a room yeah
go ahead I'm gonna take out the trash
I'm gonna do the laundry I'm gonna get
my oil change [ __ ] the long golden
to-do list stop saying that you have a
new year's go when you don't intend to
do it don't tell your friends and family
but you're gonna be a better human being
when you intend to stay a piece of [ __ ]
don't tell me that all of a sudden you a
better person than Jesus ends in your
life and the next day I see you on the
news
Robert Bed Bath & Beyond huh personally
I always fall through with my goals I
just want you know why tell people I
just kind of make sure there's hard to
figure out I told everybody last year
that I was gonna have the body of a god
and you can't say anything because I do
I just look like Buddha have realistic
goals don't say things that you know you
can't do well turn if you put your mind
to anything well you can do it Joe
positive s up let me tell you something
there are certain things in this world
that not everybody can do and
it's nothing wrong with that for example
I mentioned this before I wanted to be a
rapper but look at this [ __ ] I'll be a
rapper look at this hot percent
every day I'm pathetic you what hey you
wait 8 no don't owe any time I read my
son have been sexually assaulted me
being able to do something and do
something well on two different things
one time is one thing to me you wanted
to be a gangsta rap you can't do it kid
you're rich you got money how you gonna
be a gangster rapper and you got nothing
to rap about put your hands on me [ __ ]
cuz imma sue your ass cuz my daddy had
the vision money I've been asked what my
new year's goal is let me tell you what
it is is to stop being broke people i'ma
let you know something about myself if
one thing I'm consistent
I've been broke my whole life but those
of you out there that think I have a lot
of money cuz I have a Mac computer B
check you've ever heard of the credit
card I don't own it hit the [ __ ] I have
but money doesn't buy happiness David
you know rich people of course you gonna
say that you bid rich [ __ ] I want to
use my credit card one day as a backup
not as a first resort the new here's my
friends remember make most of your life
take take take it take it a son me what
the stunts oyster crack open / make oh
one more thing
my mom is actually in Korea right now
and I need to get to see her for the
holidays so um this is to my mom for
those of you who do not know how to say
Merry Christmas and Happy New Year's in
Korean this is how you say
baby I just wanna cut you girl now I
can't
I got a promise show [ __ ] so many
channels and kissing the focus she's
single